-Our next guests
are comedians and writers
whom you know from their work
on "Saturday Night Live,"
which airs this Saturday
with host Timothee Chalamet
and musical guests Boygenius.
They wrote and starred
in "Please Don't Destroy: The
Treasure of Foggy Mountain,"
which is streaming
on Peacock November 17th.
Let's take a look.
[ Organ playing ]
-Whoo! Yay, baby! You got this.
You're so good.
-Go, Mart!
-Thank you guys
for coming, by the way.
I know it means a lot to him
that you're here.
-Amy, of course.
What the [bleep] is her deal,
man?
-Shut up.
She's right next to us.
-What is her problem?
-She's fine, man. She's --
She's honestly really nice.
It's just...
I don't know why
Martin is so --
-Afraid?
He's petrified right now.
-It looks like
he's being held at gunpoint.
-I know, and what the [bleep] is
going on with that suit?
-I don't know, man.
-It's huge, dude.
He looks like the [bleep] sun.
-He looks like a pimp
in a high school play.
-I baptize thee in the name
of the Father,
the Son and the Holy Ghost.
You are now baptized.
-Whoo!
That was so good.
[ Applause ]
-Please welcome to the show
from the comedy group
Please Don't Destroy,
Martin Herlihy,
John Higgins, and Ben Marshall.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome, gentlemen.
-Hi!
-I'm so happy to have you
and such nice timing.
I also though
want to compliment you.
You were going to come
no matter what.
We just weren't going to talk
about the movie.
And as someone with a show,
I appreciated
that you were not
going to leave us scrambling.
So thank you.
-We love Seth Meyers.
-Oh, that's very kind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I been a huge fan of yours
from even before "SNL."
We were actually talking about
working on a project together.
I mean, you guys
are still young,
but I felt like you
were even younger then.
That's how time flies.
-Yeah, I remember
we were at dinner with you
when we got an offer
to play our first college.
-Yeah.
-At Iowa State University.
-Iowa State. Yeah.
-And we were like, "This is
going to change our lives."
-It was the best
because you guys were so happy.
I remember,
I think John got the e-mail
and we were in the middle
of dinner and you're like,
"Guys, drop everything."
-"Dude."
-"We're going to Iowa!"
[ Laughter ]
-At dinner with Seth Meyers.
It's like,
"Shut up, shut up. Iowa State."
-In their main arena?
No, it's like
a smaller theater in the...
-It's going to be
about half full.
-But I remember -- I don't know
if you guys remember.
I was like, "Oh, try
to not forget. This is awesome."
Like as happy
as you are today.
It's a hard thing to hold on to.
But you guys were --
-Much happier then.
-Yeah. Much happier then, right.
Because now you're on "SNL"
and you have to fail every week.
-Yeah.
-Or the potential of failure
is very real.
This is the third season
for you guys.
Certainly from watching
on the show,
you guys have an incredible
success rate with your shorts.
But does it feel
more at home now?
-Maybe.
-Yeah.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
We do.
-Were you going to say no?
-I was going to say
maybe next year but I...
-I feel more at home in that,
like, this is our home
because we, like, live here now.
-Yes, yes.
-We used to stay here until
like 6 a.m. two nights ago.
-In the sense
that home is where you sleep.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Who among you, like,
for example, Bad Bunny,
you did
a wonderful sketch with him
where he was dressed like Shrek
and he was pitching you guys
a Shrek sketch.
So I'm going to guess
that one came up late at night.
[ Laughter ]
And like, who among you has
the first seed of this idea?
-That was Marty.
-Marty had that.
-And how does it come
to you, Martin?
-I think it was
a panic sort of situation.
-Yeah.
-That one.
But that one, we wrote it.
We like maybe started it
at like midnight or 1:00,
and then we added some stuff
throughout the course
of the week,
and then the final edit
is exactly what we wrote
at midnight.
-Oh, see, that happened a lot.
Sometimes you would write
something,
it would get picked
and then you overwrite it.
-Yes.
-And then you realize,
oh, weirdly, the crazy idea
we had was the best idea.
I will say to your credit,
Martin, that is a funny idea.
[ Laughter ]
Were you worried
when you came up with it?
"Oh, I bet a lot of other people
are writing him as Shrek."
[ Laughter ]
-It's so top of mind
right now.
-It is.
When you see Bad Bunny,
you're like, what if?
Alright, so the movie,
you guys want to set up
the premise
of the film real quick?
-Yes.
The movie, it's crazy at "SNL"
because we just play like Ben,
John and Martin,
these like friends
who work together.
So in this movie, we got to play
Ben, John and Martin,
who work together.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
For me, it was thrilling
to see the departure.
-Yeah, it's nice.
-We have so much range.
-Yeah.
-Did you ever consider
giving yourself different names?
-No.
-Yeah.
-We thought about it
for a second,
but I couldn't imagine being
like, "Steve, don't do that."
[ Laughter ]
-"Shut up, Eric!"
-"Eric!"
-We both went with Eric.
-Yeah.
-We did.
Yeah, but the movie,
it's about three losers
named Ben, Martin, and John.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-That's not funny.
[ Laughter ]
Who, like, are
feeling stuck in their lives.
And they think the way to change
that is to go out
and find treasure
on their local mountain.
Kind of like "Goonies"
for 27-year-olds.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It has a very nice --
I mean this in a genuine way.
It has a very good "Goonies"
vibe.
-Thank you.
-Yeah.
-You told us that you
watched it on your phone, right?
-I watched your movie
on my phone, yes.
And the last time I watched
"Goonies" was on an airplane.
[ Laughter ]
But you had some very good
casting, Ben, for your father.
And were you excited when this
person said they would do this?
-I couldn't believe it.
-I'm guessing it was like
your first thought was like,
"What if this person
would say yes?"
-Yeah, no, he was about 15th
on the list, and...
Yeah. No, it was amazing.
I mean, do you want to show?
-It also kind of makes sense.
I mean, if Conan O'Brien's going
to play any of your dads...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
-He's very good.
-Yeah.
-He's so good.
And he's weirdly never played
a character in a movie
that is not Conan O'Brien.
-Right.
-So it was like
the first time he got to act.
-Hopefully you guys
weren't judging that
as you're still your own names.
[ Laughter ]
-"Oh, you've never
played a character?
What a loser. God."
-So, I mean, it must have been
so cool when he said yes.
And you guys get to sort of
break him as an actor.
I feel like that's
really thrilling.
-Yeah, it was fun to teach him
how show business works.
-Totally.
-No, it was amazing.
I mean, he's such a legend.
We've all grown up on his stuff.
So it was really cool.
-The clip was
a very good example
of my favorite thing
in this movie
is how lovingly you
all just make fun
of each other constantly.
This is a very lovely
through line
in a lot of your shorts as well.
And I think it works
because we can tell you guys
like each other.
When you write these jokes
where you're just like laying
into your closest friends,
is it ever too close to the bone
or is it always just joy?
-It's...
Yeah, sometimes it hurts. Um...
[ Laughter ]
What about something about
how your head's really big?
Maybe.
-We had something in one video
where we called Martin
like a melted
Harry Potter action figure.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And that one
bordered on too mean.
-Just being like...
[ Laughs awkwardly ]
-I think most of the time,
the relief that we have thought
of a joke surmounts anything.
-Oh, right.
So you're like, you don't even
care that it's at your expense.
You're like, "If this is
a laugh, we will take it."
-It works. Put it in. It's done.
-Yeah.
"We'll talk about it
in 15 years in therapy.
We do not have to deal
with this now."
You guys also,
I'm just wondering,
like when you're on set
and obviously, you know,
Judd was probably on set
a fair amount of time.
You got Conan on set.
And it's this movie
you guys wrote.
Was it surreal, like,
as you were shooting this thing?
-Every day was --
Every day was a dream.
I couldn't believe -- We grew up
on Judd's movies.
And to be able to do one
with him was like mind-blowing.
-Also, like 90% of our videos,
we shoot in like a 10x10 office.
-Yeah.
-And so we were like,
there's a scene in the movie
where I'm being flown up
on a crane in a wing suit,
like on a mountain,
and it's just like the scale
was unbelievable.
-It was crazy.
And it was 102 degrees,
like every day. We were in
North Carolina and it was --
Yeah, it was wild.
Yeah, it was really hard.
-They say at 102, you want to be
in that wing suit.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, definitely.
-They had umbrellas
because the sun was too intense.
-I had a guy come up to me
and said,
"The science says
if you take your shoes off,
you'll cool down faster."
Like, it was like a wax suit
that was like trapping
all the heat in.
I was being raised
closer to the sun.
Guys were like pouring
water bottles inside of me.
I was like, "Let's do
another one. Let's go again.
Ah!"
-Whenever a guy is
like, "The science says"
and it's like shoe-related,
it might not be a scientist.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. You guys, you did
something very cool today,
which I want
everybody here to know.
You put the first four minutes
of the movie on YouTube,
so right now you can
go check it out.
It's very funny from the second
the movie starts.
So I hope everybody will go
do that and check that out.
-Thank you.
-Thank you so much.
-Just one long YouTube
video basically.
-Yeah.
-That's what movies are.
-And then how are -- my last
thing before I let you guys go.
How were you feeling
about this week?
Are you excited
about "SNL" as well?
It must be a trippy week
to be promoting a movie,
and also to know
that Lorne doesn't care
and he wants you
to have a good Saturday.
[ Laughter ]
Lorne right now
is probably like,
"Oh, are they promoting
their movie?"
[ Laughter ]
-That is the vibe.
-That's the vibe. Yeah, yeah.
Guess what.
You're not imagining it.
-No.
-No, we did "The Tonight Show"
on Monday
and he was like,
"You're late for pitch."
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-That's what he does.
That's how he gets the best work
out of you guys.
And he certainly has.
It's so lovely
to have you guys here.
Congratulations on the movie.
Congratulations on "SNL."
You guys, that's John Higgins,
Martin Herlihy, Ben Marshall,
Please Don't Destroy.
"SNL" airs this Saturday
at 11:30 right here on NBC.
"Please Don't Destroy:
The Treasure of Foggy Mountain"
streams on Peacock
November 17th.
That's right around the corner.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."